What was it like growing up in the
Midwest in the 70?
[inaudible]
I think it was probably more like
growing up in Hawaii or Washington state
or Florida in the 70s.
Then it was like growing up in the
Midwest and other decades.
I think if it was mostly the seventies
and those were the same everywhere,
um,
maybe we took it a little bit less
ironically.
Um,
all of that kind of personal growth and
self realization stuff.
The seventies,
we really bought it again maybe just for
a critical year or 18 months longer.
But,
um,
that's enough to kind of set the hook.
I think it's about a prolongation of
innocence of it's a prolongation of
childhood.
Um,
that's,
that's how I would describe the Midwest.
But there you are just so far from a
border or a coast that,
uh,
the possibility of cynicism takes just a
little longer when it hits,
it hits full force cause you'd have to
embrace that cynicism and that irony in
that rage,
uh,
because you've been duped because you
have survived to a greater age with your
innocence and that is,
and you feel so betrayed by the world
then that,
um,
the first reaction is to become
unbelievably cynical and hard.
Uh,
but there is that kind of soft caramel
center that never goes away.
Maybe that's just,
I'm just generalizing for myself,
but,
uh,
I know that I was an unbelievably
innocent 18 year old,
um,
in every way,
but not stupid and not unaware of the
world.
But Justin some I somehow still thought
it was a nice world.
Well,
freshman year at college,
basically I went to Philadelphia,
um,
oh,
it was not Philadelphia's fault.
I love Philly.
Um,
and it wasn't those other kids fault.
They come from somewhat
tougher east coast schools.
Um,
a lot of private school kids.
I mean,
wow.
The,
the voltage between their jadedness and
my innocence was bound to make one of us
unhappy and it wasn't going to be them.
In some respects,
it's never really been ruined.
Um,
there's something about this whole
narrative that makes me uncomfortable
because I really don't truly don't
believe in the midwestern ness of the
midwest.
Um,
I cannot get outside it and account for
it.
I believe it exists.
Um,
but it sort of like the center of the
earth.
You know,
I,
I don't actually know for sure that we
have,
uh,
a molten core.
I just,
I'm told we do and there's no reason to
doubt it.
And they've been,
they've been there must be there.
Uh,
and the Midwest,
Midwest,
which is kind of the,
the molten core of the country.
That must exist too.
Whenever
anyone asks me to generalize about the
Midwest,
I could want to come back and say,
there is no such thing as the Midwest.
And every once in a while someone says,
you know,
there's no such thing as the Midwest.
And then I want to argue with that
person and say that that's not true.
Have you ever watched a bit western or
get on the subway in New York City?
It was certainly true in my high school
that fashion's got there a year or two
later than they did on the coast.
Um,
what we thought was very,
very cutting edge had,
was already passe and in California and
New Jersey,
as I bitterly discovered when I went
east to go to college.
So what that time lag represents?
I'm not sure I just a midwestern values
midwestern values.
I don't think there is such a thing as
Um,
I mean,
it's kind of the crank capital of North
America right now.
That was wonderful,
midwestern plain states.
So,
um,
it's not like,
what do you say?
Uh,
it's no different from anywhere else.
Um,
and yet we all feel that there is
something there.